Welcome back everyone Marvel has reportedly cast
the rest of the main Fantastic Four actors in
their couple big surprises we already know a
lot about the new movie that they're doing so
I'll explain how that fits into Avengers 5 Kang
Dynasty in their plans for Avengers 6 Secret Wars
and all those characters going forward if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos and we're still doing that
Spider-Man across the spider-verse giveaway for
tickets I'll name another winner during the video
my review for that will post on Wednesday if you
haven't seen the news in your feeds this past
week though a bunch of sites have been reporting
that all four main members of the new MCU version
The Fantastic Four have been cast there's lots of
Galactus casting news I'll address that later in
the video too just starting with the mains though
apparently Adam Driver is going to be the new Reed
Richards of the MCU I talked about this a couple
weeks ago because there's been early reports
about him speaking of Fantastic Four and Reed
Richards Elizabeth Olsen talk about Doctor Strange
Multiverse Madness and John Krasinski had a funny
reaction to this recently because she doesn't keep
up with all the Multiverse story of it all she
she only really pays attention to the stuff
she's in so she was really confused as to
why it was a different actor why it wasn't
just John Krasinski coming back to be Reed
Richards in the MCU said Adam Driver is going
to play that character I know but why did John
do it because different multiverses there
you go okay there you go I understand now
she's like that all the time when she was taking
the lie detector test about John Krasinski read
Richards she actually didn't know who the smartest
man alive was she didn't know in the comics that's
also what they call Reed Richards and what they
call him during the movie her brain just didn't
make the connection that they were talking
about Reed Richards do you think this man
is the smartest man alive no it wasn't even like
I'm really good at like hiding a lie like I have
no idea why they're asking me that question and
I also didn't shoot with him but I knew he he was
going to be in it right there's a lot we can say
about Adam Driver as Reed Richards but casting him
it sounds like Marvel wanted a much darker more
hardcore take on the character Adam Driver was
also reportedly considered for the new version of
Dr Doom as well in most people thought of Doctor
Doom when his name was mentioned like wow he make
an awesome Doctor Doom just because he's known for
playing that type of really dark Broody character
that Doctor Doom is but it sounds like this new
version of the Fantastic Four is going to be way
more serious than the last versions that we've
seen before like a Time runs outrage Richards if
you didn't read that storyline it's the one that
leads up to Secret Wars with all the incursions
destroying all these different universes in the
Multiverse during it read Richard's just flat
out goes kylo Ren bully Maguire let those other
universes die everything dies no reason to cry
about it okay little Goblin junior gonna cry
that was before they knew what was going on why
the incursions were happening that the beyonders
were behind them in the MCU it's going to be
the Council of kangs that are coming for them
Kang Dynasty sort of replacing that part of the
storyline in the comics but think of it this way
now Adam Driver can play both Reed Richards in
the MCU and he can also play the maker from the
Ultimate Universe if you didn't read those Comics
that's just an evil version of Reed Richards from
the Ultimate Universe miles morales's Universe in
fact that version of Sue Storm from that universe
that Invisible Woman becomes a version of
Kang eventually that's how hard they roll
in the ultimates universe and speaking of the
new Sue storm Invisible Woman reportedly it's
gonna be Margot Robbie of all people which is big
surprise to me because James Gunn said that she
would continue to be Harley Quinn in the new DC
movies rebooted universe and that's in spite of
all the Fantastic Four Marvel stuff like it sounds
like he kind of knew that that was going on behind
the scenes hey guys sorry I'm late let's go number
two good to know I don't have quite as much of an
opinion about her or an opinion about the Sioux
store on character as I do about Reed Richards and
Adam Driver but I definitely think she can pull it
off and I don't think she's quite at Chris Pratt
levels of overexposure like she's in the Barbie
movie that's coming out real soon there's memes
everywhere we'll take four tickets to the Barbie
movie please but the Adam Driver casting kind of
explains the tone and the vibe of this version
of the Fantastic Four just in general like Adam
Driver does have a little bit of humor in some of
his characters like he's not all seriousness but
it's just a much darker take a much darker tone
so flowing with that Margot Robbie would be a
slightly more serious version of the character
than Jessica Alba's version the new version of
the thing will reportedly be David Diggs who
most of you might not recognize because he's
going to look like a giant rock creature kind of
like Korg once he gets his powers but his biggest
stuff before this was Hamilton he was in a new DC
Super Pets movie as cyborg so he's already been in
the DC Universe before this he was also in some
of the animated Star Wars series he did the new
snow piercer series talk about fantastic 4 Marvel
connections which was based on the movie that was
originated by Chris Evans the original Human Torch
in more recently like literally as I'm making
this video he is the voice of Sebastian the crab
during the new Little Mermaid live-action remake
don't worry he is not gonna sound like that during
the Fantastic Four movie he's a great actor so I
am interested to see what his Ben Grim is like
obviously going to be very different from Michael
chiklas's version of the character supposedly
they also tried to do the new version of Ben
Grimm during the She-Hulk series but it would have
been human form Ben Grimm and I think the reason
why they decided not to do it is just because it
created too many continuity errors and because of
what it sounds like they're doing with the actual
story of the Fantastic Four movie in the new
version of their backstory I'll explain that story
in a second the new version of Johnny Storm Human
Torch though is reportedly going to be Paul mascal
who's mostly done a lot of smaller and Indie stuff
I wouldn't call him a total unknown but of all
the different Fantastic Four actors he would be
considered the Newbie to to big budget comic book
special effects heavy movies like this here's the
interesting thing about their new backstory in
the MCU the designer that Marvel hired for the
movie is mostly known for doing period pieces so
a lot of people think that this is evidence that
they're going with that crazy fan theory about
the Fantastic Four being from a different time
period and then time traveling to present day
before Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars
meaning that the Fantastic Four scene during
Doctor Strange Multiverse Madness with John
krasinski's Reed Richards was actually meant to
be a teaser for the new MCU version of the team
hello Stephen Fantastic Four didn't you guys
chart in the 60s originally most people assumed
that that was more of a Beatles joke because the
Beatles were called The Fab Four back in the 1960s
in the Fantastic Four debuted in the comics in the
1960s but now the rumor is that the MCU Fantastic
Four either came from the 1960s the whole time or
they were thrown back in time after an accident
in the Fantastic Four charting in the 60s it's
just a reference to their adventures in the 60s
trying to find a way back to the present day and
also fighting super villains of that era one of
the other side Easter eggs like one of the reasons
why Kevin feige wanted to bring the Fantastic Four
to the MCU before he did a brand new version
the X-Men team is because the Fantastic Four
are Marvel's first family like literally and
metaphorically they started in the early 1960s
way before the Avengers way before the X-Men and
also because the Fantastic Four hadn't really
gotten a great movie yet even though there'd been
a lot of bad X-Men movies there have been a lot
of really good X-Men movies too can Kevin feige
also wanted to bring back some of the more popular
X-Men actors first like Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
Patrick Stewart as versions of Professor X even
Ian McKellen's Magneto is supposed to come back
in Deadpool 3. so he wanted to bring all those
people back before he did a whole new version
of the X-Men with recast actors also there's
the whole idea everything going on with Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty Secret Wars and Reed Richards has
such a strong connection with Kang in the comics
Kang for instance originally debuted in the early
Fantastic Four Comics is Rama Tut that's why Kang
is mostly a Fantastic Four character so it just
made sense to do their team first long term it
sounds like Marvel's plan is to try and position
the new Adam Driver Reed Richards is one of the
de facto leaders of the MCU the way that Iron Man
and Steve Rogers Captain America were during the
infinity Saga movies it's just that we're starting
to get more teams now in the MCU just in general
whereas before it was just the Avengers so it
sounds like Reed Richards is going to become one
of the most important characters that they have
or they would like him to to become one there's
been a lot of stuff that's happened that Marvel
did not plan for like originally I think the
idea is that Chadwick boseman's black panther
would become that big leader in the MCU and they
were going to position all their movies around him
they still have Tom Holland Spider-Man he's
still going to continue to be in the movies
and I think he'll continue to be one of the
biggest characters that they have he's also
one of the most popular characters in the history
of the world like Spider-Man Batman and Superman
are the three most popular characters in
the history of the world just in general
but I think Marvel originally had all these plans
for the Black Panther character before he passed
away I don't know if they have plans to do their
children right away Franklin Richards and valyria
John krasinski's Reed Richards in the 838 Universe
said that they already existed outside the MCU and
the reports on Doctor Doom right now are that
he won't be a big character in this first new
Fantastic Four movie they're waiting a little bit
longer to do his character but there'll probably
be some Easter eggs and references to him during
the movie and I just did a video for Kevin feige
and John Favreau talk about Doctor Doom about how
Robert Downey Jr almost became Doctor Doom in the
Marvel movies that would have been a very very
different version of the character like imagine
a much more unhinged crazy energy Doctor Doom I
am Iron Man but make it Doom I am Doom totally
glad that he was cast is Iron Man instead Kevin
feige even says he believes they wouldn't have a
studio were it not for the success of that first
Iron Man movie so they owe a lot of Marvel Studios
to Robert Downey Jr speaking of Dr Doom though
reportedly the villain of this new Fantastic Four
movie will be Galactus like they're going to full
Galactus way sooner than I expected so we'll find
out what's going on with that pretty soon I just
did a big Galactus video there have been some more
casting announcements about that so I might do
another one pretty soon too and speaking of X-Men
there's a bunch of good X-Men news that I'll do
a video for later this week in my full Spider-Man
across the spider-verse review we'll post on
Wednesday so look out for that congratulations to
barracuda please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your contact details you're
the giveaway winner for my last big Marvel video
everyone click here to learn about Robert Downey
Jr's version of Doctor Doom and click here for
that real big Avengers Secret Wars announcement
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!